On any given page, like this one, you can open the con
developer tools by clicking on the shortcut listed in tools, developer tools.
As you can see, Chrome def tools provides a series of tabs that allow you to
debug and inspect your web apps. For example
you can select any element on the page by
right clicking the element and selecting inspect element
or as I'll do here you can click
on the magnifying glass and hover over the
area that you would like to inspect. Let's take
a look at the un-ordered list of floor selectors.
Let's change the text in one of the floor selectors. We can do that by
simply expanding the element that contains it
and then editing it live on the page.
You can also make live edits to the
CSS. Let's take a look at changing the selected
floor class. Here, I can set the background
color to whatever I want. For example, blanched almond
because who doesn't like blanched almonds. Because the
background color is now pretty light, we may also
want to change the text color. Chrome Depth Tools
provides a handy color picker for that. We can
pick any color we want. [SOUND]
Shift + clicking the color picker, allows you to cycle through
the different color schemes. RGB HSL, and so on. If we scroll a little bit
further, so our floor selector class, we can play around with the different
settings there. You can use the scroll
wheel to cycle through the different sizes.
And we can set the border width in a similar fashion. As you can see, Chrome Dev
Tools provides with rich functionality to edit and
inspect your pages. And than was just one tab.
We'll be diving deeper into the Network, Timeline,
and Profiles tabs with Colt McAnlis in the performance
lesson, and we'll cover the Resources tab in
more detail in the lesson about offline and storage.